welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and shonchi is the latest marvel
title to ask what the hell is about to
happen a mysterious beacon in the ten
rings but also we got peter parker
tampering with doctor strange's spell to
resurrect dead multiversal villains and
then a cryptic emergence in eternals and
then what if making up new timeline
rules like absolute points it all seems
to be pointing to the same mad
multiversal future but as we're still
trying to digest loki in one division we
are in desperate need of an antacid
explaining what is causing what who is
summoning whom who broke doctor strange
and why is wong everywhere i mean not
that i'm complaining really there are 10
moments in which characters in the mcu
seem to cross a threshold which we now
might be able to consider to be nexus
events or absolute points or watcher
winks event one doctor strange uses the
time stone to look ahead at 14605 future
outcomes and secretly devises a plan
that requires iron man to die event two
during the time heist loki steals a
tesseract becomes a variant event three
loki and sylvie touch creating an
unprecedented nexus event event four
sylvie kilsey who remains in the sacred
timeline splinters event five the
avengers snap back thanos's victims
which according to the eternals creates
an energy surge that triggers the
celestial's emergence event six wanda
maximov creates the westbuhex reality
and absorbs agatha's magic to become the
scarlet witch a nexus being more
powerful than the sorcerer supreme event
7 the scarlet witch reads the dark hole
and then suddenly looks up upon hearing
the voices of her sons event 8 chongqi
uses the 10 rings to kill the dweller in
darkness alerting camaratage to a beacon
inside the rings summoning something
from afar event 9 doctor strange
conducts a memory wiping spell but peter
parker interferes with it causing things
from alternate universes to collide with
this one and then 10 alt universe doctor
strange absorbs mystical beans and saves
christine palmer violating an absolute
point in that universe and destroying it
now sure there are other big turning
points in the mcu but so far these are
the events that we could argue unraveled
the fabric of the mcu as we know it no
no when we talk about causality among
these events it's important to consider
chronology because it would be easy to
say that the 10 rings beacon is
summoning the celestials with eternals
coming next in the pipeline but details
in shengqi established this movie to
take place sometime in summer 2024 in
the year after the blip but eternal
seems to be set in fall 2023 the seven
days immediately after the blip ended
this would adhere to eternal's original
planned release before wandavision and
before shang chi now loki suggested that
all the events in the sacred timeline
are unfolding simultaneously from the
perspective of the citadel at the end of
time so that discovery that the time
code of agatha's depower drop in one
division syncing up weirdly perfectly
with the timecode of he who remains in
loki testing gravity on his desk is
technically valid as would be the case
to be synced up the moment peter
derailed the spell and when sheng chi
kamehameha the mega soul sucker the
point being that every nexus event that
seems to break reality in the mcu could
be part of a multi-harmony chord that
collectively cracks the universe to
spill its contents in a multiverse mess
the more crass among us might call this
the brown note i'll just say look it up
actually don't but to determine which of
these events are part of that harmonious
fart we have to revisit the difference
between timelines and universes a
distinction that i may have rushed
through too quickly in my last what-if
breakdown apologies i try to fit a lot
in and there's always the pause button
the confusion came from a line from the
ancient one i drew upon the power of the
dark dimension to split the timeline
allowing for two of your possible
timelines to occur in one universe ah
see during loki some use the words
timeline and universe interchangeably
when actually we should consider
timeline to mean that wavy stream of
time and the branches that snake off it
while universe to be the two-dimensional
plane that all those branches snake out
into and across a universe contains a
timeline and its branches in a way that
a country contains a river too many
rivers that snake off each other the
land mass floods and the universe of
this land mass becomes too indiscernible
to the ocean that surrounds it but
whether or not you think you can trust
this person you know one famous
character we could not trust is
goldilocks that little jerk had a
terrible sense of entitlement and i
think she's technically a felon for
breaking into those bears home and
eating their porridge but you know what
you can't knock or desire to have a bed
that was just right for her we all want
a comfortable mattress designed just for
us and that's why healing sleep is to
thank for sponsoring this video helix
sleep makes premium mattresses and
bedding that are customized to fit your
needs and conveniently shipped right to
your door helix says a sleep quiz that
matches your unique body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you i took the quiz and got matched with
the dusk luxe helix mattress because i
wanted a medium burn mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool i've had
my helix mattress for over a year now
and i love it it totally delivers on all
the great features if you sleep with a
partner both of you can take the quiz
and find the mattress that meets both of
your needs and the best part about all
this is that helix delivers your
mattress right to your door for free it
comes rolled up in a box and it's super
easy to set it up yourself it's wild
that they can fit an entire mattress
into a box that size felix has a 100
night sleep trial so you get more than
three months to make sure that you love
it and if you don't they'll pick it up
for you and you'll get a full refund i
love my helix and i think you would too
if you're looking for a new bed check
out helix you can click the link below
or go to helixsleep.com
new rockstars and get up to 200 off your
helix mattress so doctor strange with
his time stone is limited to reliving
and re-experiencing events in his own
timeline and seeing the future of that
timeline that's what he saw in infinity
war and he does not create branches by
doing this however like the scarlet
witch he can absorb the power of other
mystic beings and power himself up into
a nexus being that can break an absolute
point but by doing so he plunges into a
darkest timeline that melts his whole
universe into inky dark matter just like
the ancient one warned about in endgame
that's why the avengers had to return
the stones because thanos snap was an
absolute point that they had to work
around and still deal with some of the
consequences of like some people being
five years older than others post blip
anxiety and soon celestial emergence
only those with a multi-dimensional
quantum view of timelines can tinker
with time without breaking everything
like kang slash he who remains his tva
and the watcher which is why i think
it's very possible that kang and the
watcher could be old friends or like
jacob and the man of black or just like
an adorable old married couple but for
other accidental nexus beings who don't
know what they're doing like the scarlet
witch or strange supreme or in my view
loki and sylvie combined aka loki
squared their universes crumble into
lovecraftian horror shows in marvel
studios in this same week opened the
floodgates to cosmic horror with the
tentacled soul sucking demon the dweller
in darkness and chongqi as it did with
dr strange's various tentacled demons
and what if different universe sure but
they function the same way mystic
threats absorbing the life forces from
each other to give themselves the power
to transcend reality so what is the ten
rings beacon summoning well based on all
of this probably not just something from
the stars despite the rings alien
mclewin origins in the comics i think if
it was an extraterrestrial beacon
captain marvel would probably recognize
it like she was in that room as the
expert of all things off world and she
was stumped but the fact that wong is
really the adult in the room the one who
warned strange and no way home and is in
a rush to get back to kamar taj and is
the person good strange wants to save
and what if at the very least to save
you
hmm i think this means that this is a
force from another dimension a force
that has now been notified that these
rings were used to kill a predator that
should not have been in this realm and
the signal comes in harmony with the
rise of scarlet witch the union of loki
variants and peter parker derailing
doctor strange's spell now that force
has been rumored to be schuma gorath the
tentacled elder god mini angled one
which yeah would reflect the tentacle
monster imagery we have been seeing
nearly everywhere else but while i think
squids are part of it really i think the
boldness of using spider-man no way home
to bring back an alt-universe sinister
six lineup it cannot be overstated how
huge of a paradigm ship that is
therefore i think that the beacon is
warning for any alternate universe that
might be able to hear this signal that
this universe's dam has just been burst
by the dweller in darkness arriving into
it and that dweller being killed along
with all these other things that we've
mentioned and on the other side of that
call think about it who are the biggest
multiverse experts who we are expecting
to come into the mcu very soon the pros
on this subject matter the fantastic
four doctor doom and then
trans-dimensional networks like the
council of kangs who was alluded to in
loki captain britain corps maybe the
more hardened peter parkers of the
spider-verse all of these forces are on
their way to answer the call a call that
sounds like
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com including this
great what if limited edition shirt you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
at eavos follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you